joining me now former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich who's executive
producer of the George Washington
documentary oh gosh the first American
now available on Amazon Prime video oh
my gosh I cannot wait to see it on
Amazon I've already watched it but new
king it's great to see you as always
very special what did you make of that
appearance today with Theresa May after
that Sun article that did have an audio
component so they did quote him but
apparently didn't quote him fully on
what he said about May how did that go
down I think sometimes Trump spends a
fair amount of time making up lost
ground that he lost and you know there
they are allies they are friends I
suspect he was embarrassed that it came
out the way it did she is a she's got a
very weak government in a lot of trouble
and that certainly didn't help any but I
thought the press conference actually
helped her and was also the tone was
about right I think it was a you know
Trump is actually had a very good trip
yeah and I think even the New York Times
admitted in a shocking editorial that he
had accomplished a great deal of what
Obama had tried to do with NATO but had
failed to do and I thought you know
Trump must have gotten a lot done if
even the New York Times said to say it I
think it's it's like this if someone
comes to our country a foreign leader
and criticizes our president or our
policies we don't much like that in the
United States I think doesn't Donald
Trump doesn't like that when we had
previous Mexican presidents doing that
about our immigration I know I hit him
hard in the radio not it doesn't feel
right so going given that interview of
the son no I agree with son it was a
ridiculous mistake it was a mistake he
said look he said a very good trip but
he clarified any apologize apparently
he's done he's done very good things
overall and he had a mistake when Trump
is a little bit like a baseball player
who strikes out but also hits a lot of
home runs and there's some balance in
there and I think that that's part of
this his style and his name and he's
still new he still is relatively notes
at a year and a half into this and still
lots of successes the criticism of the
president and I got to play this for you
this was
Tom Donilon former national security
adviser for Barack Obama today on CNN
let's watch I would not have the summit
in terms of the one-on-one meeting I
think this president you would tell him
counselor I wouldn't a schedule it in
the first place it wasn't well prepared
there are no goals it wasn't coordinated
with the allies we don't have the kind
of unity you'd like to have coming into
something like this there are no goals
how many how many summits did Barack
Obama have that ended up being more like
just parties that kept the catering
office you know well busy in the White
House that's ridiculous I think it's
inappropriate to measure the comments of
an Obama era official as though they're
real I mean these people represented a
world view of weakness they represented
a world view of quote leading from the
from the rear they represent a world
view John Kerry's model of being
secretary today was any for heart star
hotel with any five-star restaurant
anytime and they then thought that was
negotiated I think that if you watch
what Trump is achieving for example NATO
members have now absolutely committed to
get to the level of commitment that
President Bush asked for President Obama
asked for Trump got him to say yes
and there are a number of these things
that are happening that I think
represent substantial gain partly by
force of his personality and he's
different from the usual
I mean people and I think a lot of it
Newt is a lot of these smart people to
Council on Foreign Relations Brooking
institution all of these well-heeled
think tanks they've spent their lives
dedicated to geopolitical understanding
and foreign policy written these long
articles most people haven't read and a
lot of them were responsible for
screwing up the post Cold War era as Pat
Buchanan said on my radio show today
this guy comes along with like no
experience and say this is ridiculous
why are we paying so much of this burden
you guys aren't coughing up more money
and why shouldn't we have a better
relationship with Putin we're not going
to agree on a lot but we talked to China
and they certainly have a much bigger
military and in many ways more
aggressive more of a threat and though
you can't say that why well I think two
things first of all what Trump is
probably the most unusual president
Andrew Jackson in that his personality
has styled his aggressiveness second I
think what drives the foreign policy
establishment crazy is that their
prestige their role in the world is
because they're really smart and they
write really good papers so complicated
for the little people to understand well
in Donald Trump comes in he says he
explains that I said well we can
actually do better any of you values all
of them because he doesn't need them so
they're all sitting around going oh my
god what if the new model became
electing a president who didn't need us
that's why you see this frenzy on both
the right and the left now the right on
the right is right let's face it these
people on the right and there's they're
about this many five they're talking
just to themselves and maybe a few
people on MSNBC and that's a dwindling
audience god bless them today these
indictments were handed down as very
long indictments Russian GRU officers
intelligence officers what do you make
of this or serious allegations hacking
into American accounts placing malware
into American a prominent Democrat
accounts like Podesta the DNC fairly
serious very simple they're very serious
they raise two questions in my mind the
first is why is it that Muller would
decide to release this just before the
presidencies Putin just it's an odd
timing I don't frankly care personally
because I think it actually strengthens
Trump's hand to walk in and say to Putin
you tell me you guys didn't do that we
just indicted 12-year people but the
second question I'd raised this is a
very interesting question if we're going
to start going after people engaged in
hacking in the United States they're
going to be so many Chinese that we
should be indicted that I think this is
a very serious standard to start setting
probably the right standard but it does
mean we're going to go after other
countries nationals in their own
homeland and indict them that'll be a
big change and Trump did say today he
would confront Russia about the question
of meddling this is before the
indictments were handed down let's watch
well we'd be talking about meddling and
I will absolutely bring that up I don't
think you'll have any G I did it I did
it
you got me there won't be a Perry Mason
here I don't think but you never know
what happens right but I will absolutely
firmly ask the question well there there
have a narrative that they can't get off
Trump's cozy to Putin and main to our
allies this is just it's a drumbeat you
hear all day long but sometimes with
your friends you have to have you have
to have a real honest relationship they
would listen to what Trump said what
President Trump said to to Chancellor
Merkel when he went right at her and
said don't accept the Russian pipeline
for natural stream to buy our liquid
natural gas instead he's threatening
Putin with billions of dollars of losses
and that was certainly not the act of
somebody who is in putin's favor well
the more we are able to triangulate with
Russia and China that's also a good
thing I mean we don't want to drive
Russia into the arms of China
that would be a disastrous point for us
and Trump sees that again someone who
has had no experience until running for
president on all these issues I think he
continues to show up so many of these
people on their supposed expertise on
matters that you know they are
complicated they are important but
Donald Trump said it doesn't have to be
this linear on all these things we can
have better relationships with more
countries he also has a model in his own
head that we live in an age when leaders
can communicate directly with leaders
ranges the whole nature of diplomacy he
does that with Kim jong-un in North
Korea he does it with the president of
China he's telling it now that the
president Russia I wouldn't bet
Churchill once said you know jaw jaw jaw
is better than war war war I would much
rather have them talking than have us
drifting more and more towards a real
country now we have Democrats saying we
shouldn't talk I mean that in the 80s
they were like all we should do is talk
to the Soviet Union when we need them I
have to ask you something speaking of
the 80s they're making this big deal of
the balloon we're gonna talk about it
later with Raymond Arroyo the big Trump
balloon and the protest yeah their
approach to protests in London remember
the protests against Reagan and against
Bush we have some of the video Reagan
and 82 bush many times London Berlin
hundreds of thousands of people in Spain
that was 82 in Berlin for Reagan we had
fires we had Hugh
mass protest and yet we're supposed to
believe oh it's it's only Donald Trump
we're the most hated we've ever been
because of Donald Trump you hear that
all day long today well listen that as
you know I spent a fair amount of time
now in Rome we recently I was in Paris I
don't think that we're hated I think
that people on the Left react like
people on the left and of course a lot
of the Reagan demonstrations were paid
for by the Soviet commissars actually
subsidizing the peace movement a lot
something which liberals don't like to
concede but I think that so if somebody
puts up a big balloon why should I mean
my first reaction is this is the best
they've got this is their idea of an
intellectual answer to trump find out
one one more point we're running late
but on the trade issue he's getting
slammed for these tariffs one of the top
most respected analysts on financial
matters from Alliance Alliance had a
great quote I think actually we can play
it if you don't mind let's just listen
to this because it blows away what
everyone is saying about tariffs and
whether Trump can win a trade war let's
watch we are winning and we will win the
trade war and I think just look at the
performance of US markets relative to
China and relative to others I call it
the Reagan moment for trade that when
people realize that at the end of the
day the US will prevail because it's a
less open economy because it's a more
dynamic economy it's like they'll see
Trump this Trump approach to trade rowdy
we're the largest market in the world
everybody else needs access here more
than we need access anywhere Newt
Gingrich very very special it's great to
see you as always we'll see you I got to
get to Rome this summer please I got to
get there